hello richard
hello steve nice to meet you fine thank
you how are you
doing very well thank you good to speak
to you well it is and i've been
following you on youtube
it's an amazing world we live in where
we can
communicate sort of indirectly and
follow people and get to know people
that we've never met you know in
different parts of the globe
yeah definitely i mean the online
polyglot community now is growing uh
week by week it seems
and it's really great to talk to you as
well after i think it's been maybe three
four years that i've been
in doing this and and you live in
macedonia
yeah that's right i live in macedonia in
the uk right now oh yes normally and uh
in
macedonia uh and uh i you did a a a
a podcast with david manseray which i
listened to which is very good and i'm
gonna post a link here
on my youtube channel and if people want
to know in depth about your background
your philosophy of language learning
they should go there it's a very good
interview both of you guys did a great
job i thought thank you very much it was
very enjoyable he's such a good person
to talk to as well he's a great
interviewer i was i thought his he's got
excellent skills at interviewing and you
explain
things i think very very well so that
was that was great
let's see if we can focus on a few
things today subjects that regularly
come up at my blog and elsewhere
and the first one is this issue of
talent like
i mean you even more so than me like you
speak more languages than i do and of
course the issue is like what about the
average person okay you can speak those
languages you know you were born with
this uh genetic predisposition or
something so so what's your take on
talent versus developing these skills
it's a funny thing i don't see it so
much as talent but
a natural desire so it's like some
people are naturally drawn to watching
sports and they can recite
all of the sporting events in a
particular field that they like the
scores when they happened who scored the
goals who
who won when they were how many cups
whatever they know all the transfer fees
and they remember this massive
information
but it's because they genuinely feel
interested in it and they really love it
now i might decide one day i want to get
into football and start looking at
football games i might not not be that
drawn to it so i'm not going to be able
to retain information as well
for me i see it as
i'm an extreme language learner and i
don't think that everyone needs to be an
extreme language learner
it's not necessary what's really good is
that everybody takes an interest to
learn enough
of another language
i think it adds an extra string to
anyone's bow and i think it gives you
another dimension to not only your
personality but the way you think about
other subjects as well
now um luca in his interview with david
says something along the lines that he's
a better language learner
in whatever how old he is 30 some odd
than he was 10 15 years earlier and i've
said the same thing i i feel at age 66
that i'm a better language learner than
i was at age 16
for several reasons one
because i'm more confident because i've
done it more times and i think my brain
has become more flexible when it comes
to accepting
and noticing different structures
different sounds and so forth and so on
so i tend to feel that the so-called
talent is something that that improves
the more you the more you learn
languages
and i often use the argument that there
are countries like sweden where people
all seem to be very good at languages
and i don't think that the swedes have
some gene
that's sort of unique to the swedes that
makes them better language learners than
the spanish for example
definitely not and
when i think of a country like
luxembourg for example where they have
multiple languages i mean many people in
luxembourg will speak luxembourgish
french german and then they've got the
largest minority of portuguese speakers
outside portugal
and in europe and also they've got a lot
of people from the balkans so they'll
have either portuguese or serbian
croatian at home as well in addition to
the three uh main languages of
luxembourg and then they'll normally
speak fluent english as well
so it's it you know it's a nation of
people who have like four or five
languages
just from the word go and you don't
think that's because they have a special
gene
so but this seems to be the biggest
obstacle and i've often felt that if you
can get people to learn one language
then they can eventually if they're
interested and i get back to your point
about the interest i mean some people
want to learn one language learn it well
they need it they have a spouse or
something
go for it
and not some other people become then
motivated to learn a second or third and
a fourth
uh but once you get over i found that
once you had that experience of actually
transforming yourself into a person who
could feel totally confident and fluent
in another language that that's the
biggest obstacle and thereafter the the
you know the subsequent languages are
easier to learn
yeah i i agree to it i mean
each new language group seems to be at a
bit of a a different step yes so um
because of
real dramatic changes in the grammar or
the way you express yourself
and
actually
strangely enough i experienced that with
macedonian to a degree because even
though it's a slavic language
there are a lot of
things in it from taken from turkish and
the way they express themselves is quite
different to say how i would express
myself in check
when i when i speak
which is quite unusual um
but there's a there are definitely those
cultural things that you you learn as
well and and that can
change things up a bit i've been quite
surprised when you mention check
how much difference there is between
russian and czech
yeah so these slavic languages it's not
like the romance languages where this
basically with the romance languages i
have the feeling that it's one language
variations of one language
but but this
so far in my experience with with
russian check is that they're quite
different the structure is very similar
between russian and czech but the
vocabulary is tremendously different
yeah we have for example with there are
certain aspects of the grammar that
remain the same
um you know with with the perfective
imperfective verbs that's the theme
throughout the right the whole group
okay but even
but even even the cases for example in
bulgaria macedonia would have cases um
in czech and russian that's
a kind of a help yes um and the same
with polish
but then if you if you go to polish
you'd find it um interesting again
because
they have um
in the past tense where you've got the
atla form which have in russian and you
have in czech right
in polish they will they will add their
needs to that
for each individual person
they'll add which an ending so
and then they'll add these endings to
for the the you form and for the
the i form
okay well let me move on then to another
subject that was raised by one of the or
several people who follow my blog
because we're talking about vocabulary
in different languages
how do you learn vocabulary and how do
you keep up with this because we both
agree that
acquiring vocabulary is is the biggest
part like time wise
it's the biggest part
uh of learning a language i mean you
just need words i mean if if i don't
understand something it's not because i
don't understand the grammar mostly it's
because i don't have the word and if i
can't say something it's because i don't
have the word so the question is you've
got however many languages 16 i don't
remember the number at varying degrees
of proficiency
how do you learn the words how do you
retain them
yeah you're right the the words learning
vocabulary is probably one of the most
challenging things because you've got so
many things that you have to learn to be
really proficient you're right
and
how i go about it well
as you said in the beginning you know
about the romance languages so when i
first started
my first language after english was
french
but there are an awful lot of shared you
know vocabulary between the two
which is a big help
and i learnt it as a kid so i learned
very unusual vocabulary in french as a
child i learnt all the animals all the
birds all the plants all the flowers the
things that you learn as a kid you know
right and as well as you know all the
little songs that you ling you learn the
lullabies and things in french
so um i picked up a lot of vocabulary
that way and also through english and
knowing the big words that you know that
i i studied at high school and
university
um
but then actually retaining new
vocabulary i find that
i have to go through and you know like
the link method you know you re it
very much
sell this point as well you really need
to keep repeating and repeating and
repeating seeing vocabulary in different
contexts right
making sure that you um that you're
aware of them and how they're used in
different ways and
it does take time for certain words to
come in and then when i see words over
and over again i think
i try and think of a little mnemonic or
little thing that will help me to to
catch the word right and and and that
often
sort of is the final
in the coffin
for it to stay in my long-term memory
yeah and do you find that um
with more and more languages it's more
and more difficult to retain the
vocabulary or do they tend to stay in
their little compartments in your brain
i'd be lying if i said that some
vocabulary didn't float away as you move
from one country to another
and there is some sort of
you know an issue with with keeping the
vocabulary current and and doing things
like that um there are words that you
know i will i would have used and maybe
it would be difficult to recall if i
hadn't used the language in a long time
especially very specific words
and
but then
there are other words that are very
similar so if you use language regular
you've got a language that's similar
you'll find that the vocabulary in that
language is retained just by practicing
the other language
um a good example of this would be
portuguese and
spanish yeah we broke up there
portuguese and spanish i agree
um yeah what i find too is that uh can
you still hear me yeah okay there you
are again occasionally the pictures
freeze a little bit but that's okay
uh people will have to accept the
technology as it is you know
uh what i find too is that um you know
the expectation that you can turn on the
language you know within 30 seconds
switch from a to b to c to d without and
say not having used the language for six
months or a year or two that it'll all
be there that's an unrealistic
expectation
however i do find that i recover very
very quickly
and it doesn't take much uh and and what
i tend to do is just read and listen in
order to bring my level up to speed and
i find that i'll recover most of the
vocabulary that i need and i also don't
mind stumbling i don't mind admitting i
can't remember the word for even the
most basic thing
often it's not the most complicated
words that you forget you'll forget the
most basic words and then you're
reminded of them and then they're right
back in place again and and i think
anyone who speaks in many languages i
think most of us are quite prepared to
stumble
when we switch back into language number
three or number four
yeah i think you know you're right it
there can be a stumbling block i've i've
been very very fortunate being that in
my work in the past and also even now my
life i have to go from one language to
another very quickly
um
one job that i was on um i used to get
the phone would come up and i'd have
which country the caller was ringing
from okay and i'd have to answer the
phone and i'd say
and another
carry
between about eight languages and um
that was fantastic for me well that also
trains the brain what we might do
richard is uh you know we've got so many
questions that have come up uh we can
talk in english probably for an hour and
i'm trying to keep track of the amount
of time here uh what we'll do is perhaps
we'll end our english uh portion and we
moved to frank and i think today
again it's hard to predict how these
things are gonna go but i think today
we'll just do english and french
and uh we'll talk about some of the
additional questions that have been
raised uh and we'll try not to cover the
same ground
okay great all right so thank you very
much and you need to hang up but uh well
actually it's better we'll hang up and
then i'll phone you again because then
my recording system will will record you
yeah great interview so thank you very
much
now you're welcome
okay to you bye